The first story
that I wanted to share
of this new work is a
story about Tiger Sharks.
Now, Tiger Sharks if
you read the literature
are described as the
most dangerous sharks
in tropical waters.
They are considered the
second most dangerous species
of shark overall
after The Great White.
They've certainly been
portrayed as mindless monsters
but in reality the
cutting edge science
that's being done right
now is showing that these
are animals that actually
have a pretty high degree
of cognition and they
have the ability to learn
and the ability to remember.
Can't get into
all that right now
but this is some of the stuff
that will be published I
think in the time ahead.
They're also one of the most
versatile species of sharks.
One day they'll be hunting
in a thousand meters
of deep Pacific water
and the very next day
they'll be in a marina
looking for fish scraps
under a fisherman's boat.
When they are born tiger
sharks look like this,
they have this amazingly
stunning pattern of stripes
which off course is where
they get the name from,
the tiger like stripes that
they have on their body.
This was a neonate just a few
days old that I photographed
in Hawaii last year.
Those stripes begin
to fade as the animal
gets a little bit older and
they're not quite as vivid
and quite striking.
But the in the 20 years or so,
I've been diving
for almost 40 years,
but for about 20
years of my career,
I was very interested
in finding tiger sharks
but had almost no success.
I would do trips to various
places but never really
found them in any predictable
way but a number of years ago
a buddy of mine that ran
or runs a dive business
out of Palm Beach Florida
discovered a place
in the Bahamas, in
the Northern Bahamas
that he named Tiger Beach.
And this is an aerial view,
I used the National Geographic
blimp to do a low altitude
aerial shot here.
And this is a place, it's
sort of a sandy, shallow,
sand flat area in the
Northern Bahamas where
these animals congregate,
you'll find on any given day,
a dozen or more of them.
So we see a bunch of
these big ol' tigers
hanging out behind the boat,
perfect day to go swimming.
As we see right here.
This is what it looks
like underwater,
this is the scene underwater.
You can swim down about
maybe 20 feet or so
and find yourself in the company
of these big tiger sharks.
Many of these are between
12 and 14 feet in length.
And they'll come up very close,
they'll give you some
great closeup encounters
not using any cages
here or anything.
And it's a pretty
extraordinary thing
to be able to see
these animals like this
and to be in their presence.
The first time I did
it, my heart was racing
through my chest but over time,
you never fully
let your guard down
but I think you relax
at least a little bit
to some extent.
Part of the approach
that I took this time
when I was out there
for this latest story
in the magazine was, to
try to show these animals,
a little bit like their
terrestrial namesake,
to try to make pictures that
looked a little bit like
a tiger on land maybe
sneaking its way through
the grasses of
India or something,
channeling my inner
Steve Winter here.
But the difference was
off course I wasn't
on the back of an elephant.
So you have be eye to
eye with these guys.
And that's what some
people like to do,
you like to just have
a little conversation
with tiger sharks,
just "how was your day?",
kinda have a little chat
here like this diver's doing.
Actually this is showing
the fact that ecotourism
has really prospered
in this place,
ever since the discovery
of Tiger Beach,
a number of companies
have sprung up.
Ecotourism dive companies
that will get you out there
and get you in the
company of tiger sharks,
like we see right here.
Sometimes it can
get a little dicey,
especially when you get
multiple sharks coming around
but, in my experiences out there
in the weeks that I've
spent out in Tiger Beach,
I have to say that they
were all very well behaved,
generally well behaved
for the most part.
Occasionally, they'll
try to eat my camera,
like this one did
right here but,
once they realize that
it's not especially tasty,
they sort of just move on.
And during my time out
there on these recent trips,
I also wanted to move
away from those shallow,
sandy places,
Tiger Beach proper.
And try to photograph
tiger sharks
out in the deeper reefs.
Because they hang out there too.
Lots of tigers in the Bahamas
and I wanted to see if I
could get the lord of reef
sort of patrolling
over these sponges
and corals that we see here.
Or to look at the behaviors
of multiple animals.
We do see a lot of different
sharks here and there
there definitely seems to
be sort of some hierarchy,
some social behavior.
It's not fully understood,
I mean to some degree,
it's usually the big shark wins,
the other one usually
goes the other way but,
there is something
going on there
that I think we'll
figure out in time.
And we see this a lot too.
Sharks with hooks
in their mouth.
And it's not relegated
only to tiger sharks,
pretty much everywhere
I go in the world,
you see evidence of
fishing pressure.
This tiger had two
big hooks in its mouth
but we see jewelry
as it's often called
on many sharks all
over the world.
It's a very troubling trend
that seems to be
happening everywhere.
And thanks to a grant from the
National Geographic Society
on these latest projects,
we were also able to fund
some research out there.
This is, on the
right of the frame,
this is Dr. Neil Hammerschlag
from the University of Miami
who's been studying tiger
sharks in this region
for some time and one
of the ways he does this
is he built this special
platform that can submerge
just below the back of our boat,
you tie it up to the
back of the boat,
and then he brings
a Tiger shark in
and I'm not sure his
insurance company
is seeing these pictures
but nonetheless,
what could go wrong.
And he brings it in and
then they work up the shark,
they do some science here.
But the standard
procedure has always been
to measure the shark,
take a DNA clipping,
maybe a fin clipping
for DNA sample,
they tag the shark usually,
sometimes that's
done surgically,
they implant a body cavity tag
so they can track
the animal over time.
But some of the newest
research is ultrasound work
that's going on right here
and that's what this woman
researcher is doing in the
center of the frame here
with the goggles.
Because Tiger Beach,
it's been discovered,
seems to be a maternity ward.
Most of the sharks there
are females and many of them
are pregnant and that
shallow warm water
seems to promote gestation.
So they're doing these
sonograms that they can keep
a videograph of and they can
see how many pups are inside
and then the tagging data will
show where the animal goes,
they don't actually have
their pups in the Bahamas,
they're going up into Northern
Florida, Georgia water,
so in terms of conservation,
this would be a very
critical habitat,
we might want to
protect in the future.
And we also did
some crittercam work.
I think most of you might know
about National
Geographic's crittercam
where they attach cameras and
various scientific instruments
to animals and let
them sort of carry it
and then it pops off.
This was the first time
that one had been attached
and deployed underwater.
So this is Neil Hammerschlag
after he just put that
fin clamp on the
tiger shark here
and he's sort of checking
it, making sure it's alright.
And then off it goes for
the better part of the day
recording both video and
all kinds of other data.
And here we can see the shark
sort of swimming around
a little shark cameraman.
Here just another example of
an animal taking our jobs.
But in any case, what this data,
I mean they only did it a little
bit while we were out there
but it did yield some
interesting things.
Most of the ecotourism
operators that are out there
felt that they knew exactly
what these sharks were doing.
They go in from one
operator to the next,
and just staying on
that shallow area.
But the crittercam
showed that in between
some of those visits, they're
making these very deep dives.
We don't quite know exactly
what's happening down there
but clearly there's
a lot more going on
in these animal's
lives than we realize.
So here's a little video
that I wanted to share
behind the scenes,
just a short video.
(soft music)
just give you a sense of what
it's like to be down there
with those giant animals
and it can be a little
unnerving at times
but as I said it's
all been pretty good.
So this, for that same
story on Tiger sharks,
I also worked in South Africa.
This is a photo my assistant
made of me on assignment
here with a tiger shark
up in the water column
and this site is a new site
that was sort of discovered
by a researcher named
Dr. Ryan Daly,
it's up near the
Mozambique border.
And what Ryan Daly found is
that there's a deep water reef
there that tiger sharks
seem to frequent,
but if we dive in the shallow
waters just below the surface,
Tigers will often rise up
and sort of check us out
and he's just beginning his
research out there to find out
what these animals are
doing, where they're going
and so forth.
But he invited me to come out
and it was a chance
for me to make pictures
in a sort of
different environment,
instead of being on the bottom.
But these are
completely wild sharks,
they're not acclimated or
habituated to humans whatsoever.
Very very wild and
you're definitely
part of the food chain
when you're out there.
And unlike Tiger Beach, you
can't stand on the bottom,
you don't have that
sort of safety blanket
of being able to
stand on the bottom.
So you're really
kind of out there.
But I have another
little video that shows
what we were doing out here.
I was living at a coastal jungle
and going out everyday
in an inflatable
so this is about a
two minute video.
So lots more work to
do in South Africa.
So these are just a few frames
that I made of those sharks
and again they have sort of
a different look up in the
blue water there,
big beefy sharks.
A little bit unnerving when
they come real close to you
but you know it's stunning
seeing this was one
that was just covered in
remoras adorned in remoras,
and it was actually a silver
tip shark in the bottom
right of the frame.
There were many other
species out there,
dusky sharks and bull sharks,
but it was the tigers off course
that I was interested in
but one sort of turning it.
It's one of those things
where you're in the water
out there you wanna
get close to them
and then all of a sudden
one turns and starts
coming at you.
You're not so sure you wanna
be close to em anymore.
It's really that
interesting dance that we do
in the water out
there well anyway,
the next shark that I
wanted to share with you,
one of the four,
is the Shortfin
Mako, the Mako shark.
And I have to say being in
the water with all sharks
is pretty extraordinary and
I love looking at all animals
but, there is truly
something very special
about being in the
water with a Mako.
I've always found these animals,
they tend to be coastal animals
but not really close, you
don't see them swimming
over the bottom.
You have to go several
miles off shore
and try to attract them,
difficult to attract.
But when you do see em
you know they just come in
all jacked up just sort
of powering their way
through the water,
just full of muscle.
And this was one that I
photographed in San Diego,
I worked in a few places,
San Diego, New Zealand
and Rhode Island, for Makos.
But this was one in
beautiful blue water
off the San Diego bite
when the sun was shining
on a beautiful
September day but,
these are very scary animals.
This is probably the last thing
that a yellow fin tuna sees
before it's lights out.
They are ambush predators.
Makos attack from below,
they have that big eye
that allows them to see very
well in deep dark waters
and to be able to look up
and see those patterns.
And then when they see a
prey fish they come up and,
they'll often bite the
tail off of their prey,
whether it's Tuna or Marlin
or something like that
and then wait for it to
bleed out a little bit,
circle around and then
come in and finish it off.
And those are the things
that are always foremost
in my mind when I'm
swimming with a Mako
and it's nipping at my fins.
I've actually switched my fins.
I used to have these split
fins that looked a little bit
like a fish and so now
I've gone with something
that like two big two
by fours on my feet,
something that looks
very un-fish like.
But yeah everything about
this animal says predator.
It's really built like
a torpedo with teeth.
Just pure muscle and
all about feeding.
Now I also wanted to share
sort of a little inside
baseball story
about shark diving.
A lot of shark operators
over the last few years
have taken to using
music on their boat
to try to attract certain
species of sharks.
There's places where they
do that with Great Whites
in Australia, other places
for Blue sharks and so forth.
But Makos are very elusive.
I've been trying to dive
with Makos for decades
and had very little success.
On this story I
had some luck but,
they are very hard to get
to come close to the boat
and a lot of times,
when they do come close,
they're just in for a
few seconds or a minute
and then they're gone.
So I've had my best luck
by trying the music thing.
I actually went out
there and tried music
but what I've learned
was that the only music
that actually works
for Makos
is AC DC.
These are just badass sharks.
I mean that's just
all there is to it.
And I'm not kidding,
we've been out there,
I've been out in San Diego
and New Zealand for days
where nothing was happening
and I look at my assistant
and say you know,
time for a little AC DC.
And not every time,
but a lot of times,
you'll see a Mako come and so,
this was one in New
Zealand which is sort of
Mako central or as they
call em there Mako.
Mako central, there's
a lot of em around
and there were days where
we had maybe a dozen or so
around us in the water.
It gets a little too
crazy when that happens.
But even the little ones, this
is another one in San Diego.
Even the little ones
come in with attitude.
They're like, they come in
hot and they're all fierce
and bitty, Makos will
just bite things.
They obviously don't have
hands and they're just
all jacked up, it's like
they're on cocaine or something.
Not that I would know.
But, people have told me.
But you know, that
one had these copepods
on its dorsal fin and
this is another one,
a bigger animal that
was swimming down
in that beautiful blue
water off California
and they often get
those parasites on their
dorsal looks like
little streamers kinda
hanging off there.
But this diving like the tigers,
I always do without cages.
It would just be impractical
to try to get photographs
because the animals
are so unpredictable,
they don't stick
around for very long
and they would almost never
come over to a cage so,
you have to sort of be
out there in the open and,
most times I'm diving alone,
because I don't want
even one other person
in the water that
might spook the shark.
But sometimes I'll
have an assistant in
and sometimes he'll carry
just a little stick,
as sort of deterrent
if the animal gets
a little too aggressive which
has happened a few times
but for the most part,
they don't do that,
they will come in and
check you out a little bit.
But these are animals
that are endothermic.
Meaning that they can
generate heat in their body.
It was Brooke Runnette
actually at National Geographic
who termed the
phrase hot sharks.
These are hot sharks because
they can generate heat
in their body and because
of that they can swim
into colder water and feed
on oilier fish and so forth.
But the Mako is also one
of the fastest animals
in the ocean.
A mako shark can swim at
bursts of over 45 miles an hour
under water, in fast bursts.
And you gotta remember,
that underwater,
the medium is much
thicker than in here
so that's probably like swimming
a 100 miles an
hour or something.
But extraordinary animals and,
in San Diego I wanted
to try to hang out
near Kelp Patties.
In the Kelp forest of
California, Kelp, Giant Kelp
will often break off and mat
up and drift along the coast
and its own little
ecosystem forms.
We get little fish
and then bigger fish
and sometimes you
get Dorado, Mahi Mahi
and fish like that.
And I spent weeks out there
trying to get a picture
of a Mako near one and
that's where we see hunting.
Didn't actually get em predating
but I don't think
anything like this
had ever been made before so,
that was a kind of a
cool thing as well.
But these are the moments
I dreamed about right here,
when a big ol'
mako shark comes in
and bites the crap
out of my domeport.
That's heaven.
But you know I honestly try
to resist the temptation
of making scary
pictures of sharks
because I really don't want
to perpetuate that myth
and enough damage has been
done to sharks over the years.
But by the same token I don't
wanna sort of portray them
as something that they're not.
I don't wanna show them as house
pets or give the impression
that they're cuddly and we
can go out and hug a shark
because they're not.
They're real predators.
So I think we have to
walk that fine line
and show them for what they
are but not over demonize them
for sure.
And with the same story I
also wanted to spend some time
looking at shark tournaments.
Because there's still a
lot of this thing going on
where there will be these
monster shark tournaments
held in various places.
So this summer I
spent a couple of days
in Montauk New York where
they hold these tournaments
for a couple of days and
they give prize money
for the biggest shark killed.
And often times it's
a mako or thresher.
But you know, I think
that the time has past
for this kind of thing,
when you consider
that a 100 million sharks
are being killed every year,
I don't really think
there is a benefit
to sort of glamorizing
killing these animals.
And the two days that
I was in Montauk,
I saw six sharks come in,
no I'm sorry 12, it was
six makos and six threshers
and every single one
of them was a juvenile.
Every single one of them wasn't
even old enough to reproduce
and, I watched them drag
these things up on the dock
and sort of cut em up.
And I saw all these
children, these kids
that were fascinated
with sharks.
But, I think it's
sort of unfortunate
that this is their
first seeing of a shark,
looking like a slayed
dragon just laid there
and that the fishermen
were some sort of heroes
for doing this.
And I have no problem
with fishing but,
I just think the time has passed
for this sort of treatment
of sharks.
And I recognize that not
everyone will get to see
a shark underwater,
probably the way
that they should be seen,
this amazingly majestic animal.
We can appreciate lions and
grizzly bears and tigers
and so forth.
But underwater these
animals are just slaughtered
and often with little regard so.
My hope is that photography
can sort of move
that forward a little bit in
terms of some appreciation.
And one of the other
things I wanted to do
with this story,
with video actually
was to show the speed of a Mako
attacking something.
So with the grant from
the Geographic Society,
I designed with my assistant
at Woods Hole
Oceanographic, we designed
a tow camera system, I
found an industrial camera
that shot at very high speed.
I could shoot at
720 frames a second.
We built this tow
camera, and I worked
with a New Zealand's
champion sports fisherman
who fished for marlin
and he would rig
a mullet bait, type
of fish called mullet
and trail it behind
the boat for marlin
but he said often times
Makos would attack it.
So I was there for
a couple of weeks
but I only got one day
where I could do it.
So I've got a two minute
video with no sound
but I'll just have a look
at that and show you,
this is the first time
this has ever been seen
of a Mako in high speed
attacking something, a mullet.
Everything that you're
gonna see here happened
in about four seconds.
But we're shooting so fast
that we can play it back
at normal speed and
it's slow motion.
But it was fascinating
to see this animal
after he latched on,
he sort of put his
pectoral fins back
in a very hydrodynamic way
almost trying to use his weight
and the speed to break it off.
The boat was travelling
at about eight knots.
And he had no trouble
off course firing up
and going in and
grabbing that bait.
But it was interesting
to see that behavior,
I think researchers, I haven't
showed this to scientists yet
but I think they'll
be interested to see
this form that the Mako assumes
once he's bitten into the prey.
Just a truly remarkable
predator for sure.
Going for a ride.
They can sort of detach
their jaws like a Great White
as well.
I hadn't realized that but
you can see it coming out.
So pretty amazing
behavior from Mako sharks
shot at 720 frames
per second well,